Let's debate whether children kept in cages
deserve things like beds and toothbrushes
and soap.
This is how far the Overton window has moved
on the issue of child detentions and separations
and incarcerations.
Uh, or to put it in another way, this is how
much creeping normality there has been on
the issue of caging children.
So let me explain those two terms because
these are important.
When I talk about the Overton window and I
say the Overton window has shifted on this
issue, the Overton window is the range of
what's acceptable for debate in the public
discourse.
Okay?
So, for example, in the area of nuclear weapons,
the Overton window, more or less ranges from
everybody who wants a new car should have
nukes or everyone should have knew sort of
on one side two, no one should have nukes.
Uh, and there should or shouldn't be international
agreements limiting who has nukes and there
should or shouldn't be punishments like international
sanctions for people for country's that violate
agreements on new cars.
Okay.
That's sort of all within the Overton window
on nuclear weapons outside of the Overton
window right now would be the position that
if a country develops nuclear weapons when
they shouldn't we capture torture and kill
the children of whoever is president or prime
minister at the time.
All right.
That's a cartoonish example, but that is a
piece of position on nuclear weapons that
is outside of the Overton window right now.
It's not.
When you hear that, you don't consider that
to be part of what is the acceptable a spectrum
of debate or position on nuclear weapons.
That's Overton window creeping.
Normality is another term where you can't
jump to where we are today.
It has to creep in slowly.
Normalizing.
So as an example, if 20 years ago someone
had said, let's radicalize half the country
on immigration so that they think Brown people
from Latin America are the enemy who are tape
taking our jobs and raping us.
And then let's start putting children who
come here with undocumented parents in cages
and we only have to debate do those kids deserve
soap and beds and toothbrushes?
That would be too much.
But that creeps in over 20 years.
And here we are debating, do children in the
custody of Border Patrol, uh, deserve and
are they entitled to basic hygiene and bedding
items.
And in fact, we have a Trump justice department
lawyer who recently insisted in court that
safe and sanitary conditions is a vague term.
And it may not include something as basic
as a bar of soap or a toothbrush or a blanket
for the fully lit cold rooms in which these
children are forced to sleep or at least try
to sleep is being able to sleep at all part
of safe and Sanitary Wild Trumps Justice Department
lawyer Sarah Fabian argued, it's not totally
clear that it is.
I'm going to play some of this video for you
of the lawyer arguing with the judges.
I'm going to show you several minutes of it
so that you can see this wasn't a minor part
of this hearing.
This is an important and key part of the hearing.
They are debating how should these children
who have committed no crime, who were just
brought here by their parents, uh, and have
been taken into custody by border patrol,
how should they be treated and do they even
deserve something like soap?
Take a listen to what took place in a court
just a few days ago.
You're really going to stand up and tell us
that that being able to sleep isn't a question
of safe and sanitary conditions.
Your honor, I think what I'd like to, what
I'd like to stand up and say, it's the focus
is the focus the court on, um, what, what
the question is.
Any number of things might fall under those
categories and I think sleep surely does,
right.
You can't be safe and, and sanitary or safe
as a human being if you can't sleep well.
And then you said in your brief suggested
say anything about sleeping.
So therefore, um, and there's nothing in here
about half being able to sleep.
I think the concern there is your honor, the
court finding that sleep for example falls
under is relevant to a finding of no safe
and sanitary conditions is one thing.
But the ultimate conclusion is safe and sanitary
is a singular category in the agreement.
And it was, it was when has to assume left
that way and not enumerated by the parties
because either the parties couldn't agreement
on how to enumerate that or that it was left
to the agencies to determine, to determine.
It was relatively obvious, uh, and as least
obvious enough so that if you're putting into
peoples in the crowded room to sleep on a
concrete floor with an aluminum foil blanket
on top of them, that doesn't comply with the
agreement.
I mean, it may be that they don't get super
thread count Egyptian linens.
I get that.
But the testimony that the district judge
believed was gets really cold.
In fact, it gets colder when we complain about
it as being cold.
Where sports does sleep crowded with the lights
on all night long and all you do put us on
as the concrete floor with an aluminum Lincoln.
I mean, I understand that some outer boundary,
there may be some definitional difficulty,
but no one would argue that this is security
energy or see a safe and sanitary, or at least
I don't think you're aren't going that.
How are you,
your honor, I think what I'm arguing is that
the way that the district court reached the
conclusion was to say these these specific
items and, and I, I think I will acknowledge,
I think sleep is, is the more difficult end
of what I'm arguing.
When you start a numerated for example, specific
hygiene items.
And the way that was done is that the, the
court in sort of enumerated these and Sadie's
to fall under the rubric.
These fall in the category of what can be
required.
It wasn't perfume soap, it was so, it wasn't,
you know, high class middle.
So it was so, and that sounds no, that part
of saved from sanitary, it's within everybody's
common understanding that, you know, if you
don't have a toothbrush, if you don't have,
so if you don't have a blanket, it's not safe
in Santa Fe.
Well wouldn't everybody agree to that?
Do you agree with that?
Well I think it's, I think those are, there's
fair reason to find that those things may
be part of savings are apart.
Why do you say maybe, maybe
this is what it sounds like.
Okay.
We are debating does a six year old separated
from his or her parents through no fault of
their own and put in a crowded crappy facility?
Do they get soap?
Do they get a blanket despite having the lights
on all night and being super cold and being
in close proximity with other people, making
basic hygiene even more important to prevent
the spread of disease and germs.
This is the debate that we are having not
only in our legal system but also, uh, in
the political world because there are Trump
is who are on apparently the side of the lawyer
that it's not clear that these children who
have done nothing wrong to deserve these things.
Now I know lots of lawyers and I understand
you argue for your client.
I've met George Zimmerman's lawyer, uh, and,
and spent some time with him and I've gotten
an interesting perspective of his view on
this issue of he have to like George Zimmerman
to believe that George Zimmerman deserves
a defense.
But then it starts to get more complicated
when you get into some of these specific situations.
You argue for your client, not necessarily
for what you believe, but how does this woman
sleep at night?
Everything that is taking place here is completely
backwards and I hate to even go to a financial
argument because for me the moral argument
and the legal argument are so obvious here,
but to make a financial argument, isn't it
much cheaper to spend some money on soap and
blankets and toothbrushes and prevent the
types of illness and disease that would spread
if kids can't sleep and can't clean themselves?
Isn't that much cheaper than having to treat
the diseases and conditions that would arise
from no hygiene in such crowded and concentrated
situations.
Although maybe the whole point is they don't
really have a plan of treating those conditions
anyway.
And secondly, if you look at what it costs
to keep these kids detained and estimates
range from $300 a day up to $750 a day or
more, how are we not able to just obviously
afford and have the soap and betting on hand,
which is why this gets to, I don't actually
think that the financial issue is the issue.
This gets back to that strict father morality
I've spoken about before, which is it doesn't
matter if we can afford it.
It doesn't matter if, if even legally there's
a case to be made that these basic hygiene
products should be provided to these kids.
There is a contingent in this country that
on a moral level believes that children whose
parents came to the United States illegally
or came to the border legally seeking asylum,
that the children as a result don't deserve
soap when the United States decides to enforce
and carry out a policy of putting these kids
in what are effectively cages.
Uh, and there are other terms we could even
use when you talk about the crowded conditions.
Um, uh, it is absolutely stunning that this
is a debate that we're having, but this is
how the discourse has gone in the United States
over the last 20 years.
The Overton window has shifted.
There has been creeping normalization of this
stuff, and this is where we are in 2019 and
it doesn't bode well for us as a society doesn't
bode well for us as an economy.
It doesn't bode well for us as a country.
It's sad and depressing, but this is the reality
today.
There are few attacks on the freedom of an
independent press that are more chilling than
threatening reporters with prison time.
And we just learned that Donald Trump has
done exactly that.
This is truly a disturbing act that it would
be great to see it cross party lines.
It should scare every single one of us.
And that includes Republicans and Democrats.
And it would be great to see both Republicans
and Democrats that are our elected officials
call this out.
But in the world in which we exist today of
haphazard and knee jerk defenses of anything
that Donald Trump says or does, I don't think
we're going to see it.